you
the nobel peace prize to the
organization OPCW is this price more to
stimulate and encourage more than a
price for what this organization has
done during its twenty years of
existence I would say both a lot has
been achieved and we are now in a
situation in which we can do away with a
whole category of weapons of mass
destruction for the first time actually
if the remaining states exceed the
convention and that those who have
exceeded to it fulfill their obligations
and of course this is a very important
message to those who are all side and
also right inside to go faster what does
the committee really want to achieve by
avoiding the price to this organization
we want to give a message to those who
are outside the convention to join the
convention and also our inside that
haven't fulfilled that obligation to do
so more speedily and also to give a
message to the world how important it is
to have such global conventions and
global institutions because we see now
in Syria that this is actually the basis
for the talks that have been started
between Russia and United States to
solve the crisis in Syria so again we
see the importance of global
institutions you mentioned Syria and
it's got this organization has been
working since 1993 but it's a work has
got a new news value in Syria does the
organization does the committee want to
press the international community to get
rid of these chemical weapons not only
in Syria but in all other countries as
well of course and the crisis in Syria
demonstrates the need to do so because
these weapons are playing a crucial role
in Syria and I mean we have seen again
that such weapons it's necessary to have
them as an international taboo and so I
mean the crisis in Syria highlights the
need for doing away with weapons but i
would say that without the crisis in
Syria I think that the committee could
have come to this conclusion also
because we have looked at this for quite
a long time will you call this price
display year's prize a prize of
disarmament strictly in accordance with
the will of Alfred Nobel absolutely this
is the convention against commit robbery
it's not about arms control it is about
disarmament doing away with a whole
category of weapons which I think goes
straight to the will of Alfred Nobel and
about this about the disarmament but
also to the only criteria he talked
about convening peace Congress's today a
piece Congress is such an organization
this is an ongoing peace Congress
actually was it an easy job or a
difficult job to conclude that this
organization should be awarded this
year's prize it is always difficult to
to pick the right on but it was not
difficult inside the committee I think
we had a very good process and this
appeared
something which everybody could agree on
and we are very comfortable with this is
this year's prize to be regarded as a
non-controversial price well I think so
but of course always somebody will find
something negative I mean the battle for
peace is controversial in itself it's
many ways to peace and therefore they
will all be always be disagreements this
year's Nobel Peace Prize to this
organization has been compared to the
one of 1997 when Jody Williams and the
international campaign against land
mines were awarded the prize is that
right yes you can easily say so that was
about doing away with another category
of weapons than the land mines we have
also had the convention against
Gloucester weapons and now we have
chemical burns Jody Williams has said to
the international press that the
committee should be ashamed of itself
for awarding the price to President
Obama what is your answer to Jody
Williams my answer is that Obama got the
prize because he paved the way for new
negotiations with Russia on strategic
nuclear weapons which President Bush had
actually canceled so the whole
international arms control regime was
about to collapse and then Obama came
rescued the whole international regime
and got a start agreement that is more
than enough to get the Peace Prize they
are in the world about 300 different
Peace Prizes but none of them have the
prestige and are such important as the
Nobel Peace Prize why do you think it's
still here so I think it's because of
the prices we have avoided and the
integrity that committee has shown
we are not influenced by domestic
politics by Paul stations or pressure
from any side we just look at the facts
we are using expertise to advise us and
therefore we are able to do to issue
prices that get a lot of respect your
mandate in the committee expires next
year at the end of next year do you want
to go on on another six-year period this
is entirely up to the European children
to the novice in Parliament that
appoints the members but as I remember
no committee members have been taken out
against his or her will and that I think
that is for political wisdom when you
enjoy the open you want to go on well
yes I enjoy it it's a very interesting
and very challenging but I mean it's up
to the nor'-east Parliament thank you
toby and Ellen